foreign
what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today would long with
John is it are you sure how are you John I'm
good I'm good I'm concerned but good G how are
you concerned citizen of Gotham City over here
Gotham citizen ladies and Gentlemen please go
ahead leave a like we're gonna talk about um this
Batman Beyond news here uh how Warner Brothers
canceled it now going through it I was like okay
maybe this is a good thing actually because when
I first heard it I've had three reactions first
one was what two uh actually you know maybe and
then oh come on that would have been awesome
so I'm gonna go through all that with you so
I think the third thing you don't know about John
that's the part I think we did not get the update
on so first order of business what was being
reported first it came through Jeff Snyder and
then the rap confirmed it and now The Hollywood
Reporter reported on it was that after the flash
they were planning a Batman Beyond movie starring
Michael Keaton with the script being penned by
I think her name is Christina Hodson is that
how you pronounce her name yeah Birds of Prey
and Batgirl as well and then when the James
Gunn and Peter saffron thing was announced or
or like when the meeting started happening
they were like stop stop writing stop stop
you and Patty Jenkins just stop everyone stop
it you're right no longer on the clock and now
here's the part of it where I was like oh man
that's a bummer when I heard what they wanted
to do with it was like yeah they wanted to do like
old man Michael Keaton as Batman which of course
is like oh that's like the dream right there
if they got Tim Burton to come back oh come on
could truly excite me with right now how excited
would that have been to finally be like that's
that's like the Dream movie right there that would
have been so good because Batman Beyond is like
it takes place in the future eventually you know
Batman he's like he's too old then Terry McGinnis
comes into the phrase trying to start beginning to
take off the Batman mantle you know how the story
goes in case you don't but that's how it is but
apparently they wanted it to be set in the current
DC Universe so they didn't want to go into the
future what yeah that's the part of it that I was
like all right maybe it's a good thing you didn't
do this I think like exactly way more than happy
people oh yeah so yeah I guess we would want like
the Robert Pattinson Batman to exist in his own
universe and then this would be part of like the
main one something along those lines bottom line
it wasn't gonna be the futuristic world that
is so heavily associated with Batman Beyond
so that's what made me go all right okay maybe
maybe that's maybe maybe it's a good thing still
still give it a shot Warner Brothers like down the
road with something but maybe do a woman actually
takes place in the future because that's such an
integral part to it then this piece of news came
out and that's when I went oh come on no no what
is it this actually excited me more than anything
else for some reason do they cast chalamet to
be Terry McGinnis yeah that's what it was man
Finn Wolfson right there yeah around the cusp yeah
no uh here's what it is they wanted to bring back
Catwoman oh like like Michelle fight and I had to
have they they didn't confirm if it was Michelle
Pfeiffer but like which mother Catwoman would it
have been yeah it would embrace the meme because
like the impression that I've been getting is
that they were gonna kind of Superman Returns
it in a way where they're gonna ignore Batman
Forever and Batman and Robin and we're just
gonna even though those are technically the same
Batman from the Michael Keaton once yeah and we're
just going to pick it up after Batman Returns
and like discount forever and Robin continue
it after Batman Returns and that Batman Returns
movie had that Cliffhanger that showed Catwoman
was still alive and then she never came back into
the fold and that Romancing and her portrayal of
Catwoman is still my personal favorite yeah it
would have been so awesome to have them reunite
on screen and none of the Tim Burton talk ever
went down according to any of these reports they
didn't say if it did or didn't but you know my
little headcan and it did or at least it may be
pondered it but if they had to come back oh my God
correct Michael Keaton and Kat one and Michelle
Pfeiffer is Catwoman that just would have been
such a cathartic fulfillment yeah and you know
he still would have been cool to get some type of
like solo Batman movie in some way but yeah the
prospect of have a fulfilling that storyline that
did not get to get fulfilled would have been just
so hype on my end so yeah that's the experience
of the Batman Beyond canceled project for me it's
funny I mean I guess at that point I had a very
interesting reaction to to these pieces of news
assembled because yeah at first I am like wait
wait a minute so if you put him in the present
he's basically just Nightwing but he's Batman but
then if Terry McGinnis comes in yeah yeah I mean
there have to be a Terry McGinnis if they're gonna
do a Batman Beyond yeah absolutely well yeah it
has to be but but like setting it in the present
day just takes away a lot of yeah what makes it
unique but then thinking about you know they're
gonna basically just make it the part three of
the Tim Burton Batman like as much as I feel like
this may be a little unfair to Batman Beyond is a
property in general it's not a bad take for those
characters at this age to pass on that mantle
which is pretty cool and yeah about the only thing
that Tim Burton could truly like excite me with
at this moment because it is like unfinished
business and it makes me hope and wonder if
it's possible for James Gunn and Peter saffron
to maybe Embrace some type of elseworld's wing
of the DC you going forward you know we live in a
day and age where it's now more and more popular
to a get the old band back together and B skip
a bunch of sequels and make a direct sequel to
something that everybody loves you could do this
in an else worlds still like they're gonna have to
do that anyway like Joker exists and is going to
keep on going Robert Patton says Batman existence
is going to have to keep on going like those are
I guess technically going to be just their own
little else worlds like give a deal and build
all the the new iteration of Batman Beyond or
whatever you talked about wanting to do that maybe
that would be really cool like and I think they
would you just like name drop them did you know
that I just thought like well actually like they
would be perfect for that I'm pretty sure they
spoke about like wanting to do that at least dude
yep got it I'm hopeful for the future but
yeah it's a bummer to hear that this is uh
ostensibly canceled I mean if Hollywood Reporter
is putting it out it must be legitimate but I'm
like wow that does seem like some dream you know
sort of DC's equivalent of a going back to the
Toby Maguire Spider-Man move yeah yeah you know
I would be curious to see if they would Embrace
doing something like that that isn't Zack Snyder
related like that's also the the only thing that
could probably surpass people's enthusiasm for
the Snyder verse is like oh man we're gonna
complete the Burton Batman that would have been
it would have been like me once I heard Michelle
Pfeiffer I was like I know I know what oh hell
here like it's ah like that no especially in
the recent years like developing more and more
appreciation for Batman Returns especially like
this is my favorite one favorite Batman of the
four especially my favorite one yeah please yeah
make it happen in some way because the thing
about Batman Beyond is it will work at its
strongest with a returning Batman who is older
that's why Michael Keaton returning was perfect
for this like it could work with a brand new
guy brand new old guy playing Batman it would
work it just wouldn't hit the punch nowhere near
as strong if you it was just some new guy a part
of the appeal is a returning Batman he's older now
you know dude 10 years down the line just do Ben
Affleck give it to Zack Snyder's Batman Beyond
oh yeah that would be great right actually yeah
Snyder will be Sykes the audience will be
right yeah and it would work excellent yeah
James Gunn uh you know I'm open for uh suggestions
that's not a bad idea at all actually that works a
lot yeah yeah it could be a cool homecoming for
everyone all right guys well what do you think
about this uh Batman Beyond canceled thingy
leave your thoughts down below you bummed
what do you want what do you want what
do you want George Clooney to do it come
on all right subscribe leave a like click
that Bell last but not least do a patreon
Lance door you're the bat you're the Terry
McGinnis of the channel because you know
you're strapping young lad you're not as brooding
as Batman I feel like Terry McGinnis is kind of
like Spider-Man meets Batman in a sensibility kind
of way more he's basically Nightwing but in the
future so so because he's in the Lance you would
fit in well in the future your buff and sexy and
handsome and and you know Charming but you got
a little bit of that badass sight you know you
work with fire man so uh you know this Christmas
I just wish uh for you to get a spandex suit
um you know like you know skin tight late
uh uh PVC or whatever that stuff is that
that gimps wear and and just you know do
a full Batman calendar and send it to us
uh we gotta get a new P.O box what will we
do send us that calendar and we'll hang it
in the background right in the middle
you can sell a bunch you can be the
new Markiplier too there you go start your
only fans buddy happy holidays feeling good